bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à leur première question
comment avez vous appris la nouvelle ça
fait tout de même plus d'un an que le
liban n'a pas de gouvernement
d'abord c'est toujours un plaisir et un
honneur d'être à votre antenne écouter
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire qu'on a un
optimisme assez précaire et timide d'un
compte et je veux dire on est soulagé on
revient sur notre constitution et qu'on
a un gouvernement à savoir que la
constitution libanaise sans pouvoir
exécutif ne peut prendre aucune décision
ne peut faire presque donc une réforme
et surtout ne peut pas gérer une des
crises économiques et sociales les plus
graves jeudi j allais dire de la région
mais je dis aujourd'hui du monde
aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr beaucoup
mieux d'avoir un gouvernement que de ne
pas avoir parce que le gouvernement des
affaires courantes n'a pas joué son rôle
n'a pris aucune décision était
complètement démissionnaire même de sa
de sa démission donc aujourd'hui après
un non on n'y croyait plus parce que
pour des pressions internes politique
régionale le gouvernement n'a pas eu
lieu nous savons que le gouvernement
qu'on a aujourd'hui a été accouché d'un
forceps on espère vraiment qu'il pourra
entreprendre les réformes et faire face
à sa crise mais quand je dit optimiste
imite il faut pas oublier que ceux qui
ont formé aujourd'hui le gouvernement ce
qui tire par les ficelles les ministres
qui ont été nommés aux autres ce sont
les mêmes ce qu'ils ont causés quand
même ce cette chute dramatique c'est les
mêmes qui sont au pouvoir depuis plus de
30 ans ils sont toujours aujourd'hui et
qui tiennent ce gouvernement ce qu'on
craint que les raisons qui ont empêché
la formation de ce gouvernement depuis
12 depuis 12 mois loose longs mois où
nous sommes tombés dans une tendance
dans une dans un drame dramatique jour
après jour dont on craint que ces mêmes
problèmes qui étaient en dehors de la
plateforme du gouvernement nous suivent
dans la plateforme de ce même
gouvernement on craint aussi que les
pressions régionales et internationales
qui ont donné lieu aujourd'hui à la
création de ce gouvernement parce que
c'est très clair il faut être très
réaliste ce n'est pas des efforts locaux
et des efforts régionaux et
internationaux
on remercie finalement mais en même
temps
vous savez que faire face à cette crise
aura lieu aussi à des décisions très
difficiles les décisions difficiles des
réformes à faire un plan de
restructuration donc on craint que à
n'importe quel gène autres onéreux ou
aussi à ces mêmes je dirais grands
joueurs régionaux ou internationaux
aujourd'hui pour faire face à cette
crise il faut qu'on ait vraiment tu veux
dire une solidarité libanaise il
faudrait que toutes les parties
politiques toutes les personnes qui sont
sur le pays soit d'accord sur un plan de
restructuration très clair très nette et
jeudi un plan à court moyen et long
terme on n'a pas encore entendu c'est
quoi les priorités de ce gouvernement on
n'a pas entendu de plans réels et à
savoir que le premier plan serait une
négociation avec le fonds monétaire
international
on n'a pas vu on sait qu'il devra
prendre des décisions vraiment très
graves comme la levée des subventions et
ça pourra entraîner un déchaînement dans
la rue donc à savoir sur ce gouvernement
s'il n'est pas nominé avant sa voie
avant de sa naissance et 3e - il ne faut
pas oublier l'échéance extrêmement
important des élections
législatives qui devront avoir lieu dans
moins de huit mois il faut aussi que ce
gouvernement puisse dire au peuple
qu'ils auront le droit de donner choix
alors alors représentants et non un
repoussement d'une échéance cruciale et
que tout les libanais attendent je
devrais des biens pour vraiment dire ce
qu'il pense de ses dirigeants même au
sein des voix et des bulletins de vote
selon vous à quel point la passe
politique et aggraver la crise
économique sociale et financière que
traverse aujourd'hui le liban depuis
trop longtemps
madame je dis malheureusement en toute
sincérité et objectivité c'est lui qui
ont créé cette crise et pas qu'il aura
grave et ils ont crié à ne pas oublier
que c'est la même classe politique qui
était directement responsable des 17
années de guerre fratricide qui le même
ont pris le pouvoir pour les trois
dernières années se sont divisés le
pouvoir et se sont divisés aussi le
gâteau dont les aides internationales et
toutes les conférences donc ce n'est pas
qu'ils ont aggravé ils ont causé la
crise ils ont créé la crise et non
seulement ça a été ceux qui ont créé la
crise mais ce qui est pire c'est qu'ils
ont été les pires dans la gestion de
crise à savoir que notre crise
économique et social a vraiment débuté
depuis la révolution du 19 octobre et
quant à la gestion de crise jusqu'à
aujourd'hui aucune mesure concrète n'a
été prise ils ont promis un audit
locales et internationales et les mêmes
qui ont promis l'audit ont enlevé
l'audit ils ont promis de faire un
support et les subventions aux familles
pauvres jusqu'à cet instant on n'a vu
aucune fille vention pouf en crète ils
ont ils ont promis d'avoir un contrôle
de capitaux spécifique ce qui est
peut-être là fait normal et juste à cet
instant a fait plus que 30 réunion on a
pas de contrôles de capitaux donc
finalement ils ont créé la crise ils ont
causé la crise et dans la gestion de la
crise malheureusement va les emmener à
une descente aux nabis nous nous sommes
aujourd'hui c'est ce que quand je dis
c'est tout le monde je ne ne différencie
pas nous sommes aujourd'hui les chefs
d'entreprise on a payé le prix le plus
cher la population paye le luxe et le
brio plus cher pour information nous
dirigeants quand ils se sont entendus
entre deux îles sont entendus pour la
division de ce gâteau pour la division
des nominations pour la division des
projets et quand ils sont pas entendus
mais aussi il on veut bloquer gelé
toutes les institutions privées et
publiques aujourd'hui nos institutions
sont complètement joly à tous les
niveaux je commence je commence par le
public pour l'un des ministères
complètement ville et à savoir que la
crise a atteint tous nos secteurs
productifs l'un après l'autre dans une
stratégie destructif très clair les
terminer ils ont attaqué le secteur de
production tous les secteurs productifs
comme le commerce comme l'industrie
comme les technologies comme
l'agriculture comme la santé et comme
l'éducation aujourd'hui que je
représente donc aujourd'hui je vous
redis c'est même des personnes qui ont
décidé sont finalement attendre a
entendu après 12 mois pour les mêmes
problèmes on sait que par une par un
coup de baguette magique ils sont
entendus mais même leur accord est
extrêmement précaire et à savoir quelles
vont être les objectifs à court moyen et
long terme mais je ne cache pas non plus
moment mon optimisme je dirais timide
parce que finalement veut mieux avoir un
gouvernement que ne pas l'avoir mais
finalement la grande question va être
quoi après le gouvernement les décisions
les grandes réformes et surtout les
négociations avec le fonds monétaire au
mois pour attirer défaut au large de
cette descente aux enfers dramatique
dans la population libanaise
complètement désemparé et désespéré fois
de je me colle merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous
président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise et
libanais dans le monde est élu doyen de
la faculté de l'ue est ce juste merci à
vous